we are getting call of duty vanguard
which is going to be set in world war ii
i'm joined here by richie bracamonte hey
what's up guys and we're gonna talk
about a preview event that we went to
now
many of you like us
didn't really want a world war ii game i
think the community was pretty open
about that and after seeing this preview
we're going to talk about whether our
minds were changed and sort of how we
felt about the setting if anything's
different after the initial impression
now richie and i wanted to just take a
quick minute to talk about the toxic
workplace environment that happened over
at activision
we are very proud of california's
lawsuit tackling this issue
nobody should feel unsafe in their work
environment everybody should feel
included where they work and that's
something that we try to strive for very
hard in our own workplace but we
understand for some of you out there
because of what's happened in the
responses that you don't want to play
another activision published title again
and we completely understand what we're
going to do today is we're going to give
you our thoughts and opinions um which
is very important to us as journalists
and we want for you guys to make up your
own minds about
what you want to do after that
okay so let's talk about call of duty
vanguard and whether our minds were
changed uh after this preview event
richie
i think you should probably start off
with sort of high level you went back
and played every call of duty game this
year so what did you think about the
world war ii setting before i saw the
presentation you know we've talked about
this at length before i was uh
i was okay with the fact that they were
considering going back to world war ii
i've liked all the world war two
iterations including very much the 2017
sledgehammer world war ii game so i was
open to the idea and i was excited for
it if that was the route they're going
at that point it was a rumor so
after the presentation however i would
say like
i was lukewarm on what's going on not to
say that it's a bad idea or a bad game i
just feel like my hype was lower than i
anticipated which was strange because
there's a lot to like there was a lot
a lot going on it was a big info dump
that you know would normally get me
pretty excited overall just leaving the
event the hype wasn't as cooking as hot
as i thought it would be how did you
feel about the whole press event what
were your thoughts a lot of what we saw
in this event was based around a
campaign
that very smartly channeled the feel of
modern warfare so the theme of this
story set in world war ii is going to be
the rise of special forces and i'd be
lying if i said i didn't want like a
special forces around the world game for
a very long time but that's pretty
genius like i think they correctly read
that the community didn't necessarily
want another regular world war ii game
and a lot of people in the community
really loved modern warfare which was
all about special operations so a lot of
these decisions that they made got me
very intrigued in this game the other
thing i want to say about the at least
the campaign part that we saw but maybe
also the multiplayer is this felt like
maybe one of the first next-gen
developed titles so we all know that
cold war was a big step back from modern
warfare the engine just didn't feel as
good this game is bringing things that
feel like they were made for modern
platforms so there's like volumetric
lighting tons of particles fire
everywhere lots of destructible cover
that gets chunked up as you go so again
like we haven't actually seen
multiplayer in action yet that's going
to be a future event but what got me
excited about this was that it was that
it was a special forces themed game
which felt very modern warfare and the
technology behind it felt like they
finally developed something for a
next-gen system that's a good point and
i do agree like this this seems like
something that was conceptualized with
next-gen or current gen in mind uh it's
a hard time right now because everyone's
still trying to get their hands on
the current gen consoles
um but even then this is something that
is looking really good every sort of
press event every sort of reveal event
like this they talk about the dust and
the lighting and particles and that's
always just been so it's always it's
always sort of flew over my head because
that's not something i really truly pay
attention to but
this this really encapsulated that like
for the first time i really noticed
without them talking about it like they
showed us a trailer to start with and i
noticed all that stuff for the first
time it really added to the moody
atmosphere of that opening gameplay uh
so that's a great start like it's a
small detail you know but it's part of
the bigger picture of next-gen so
overall i would agree and say that this
game is looking good and it seems to
have next-gen put first in terms of uh
you know production another aspect of
this that was interesting because i
think you and i looked at this from very
different perspectives but let's talk
specifically about guns in this game so
what did you think about the the gun
play that they showed off the gun play
i'm kind of split on this for a few
reasons but
overall it's it looked good it looked uh
they really try to emphasize something
that's hard to do
without your hands on a controller they
they try to describe the gun play very
thoroughly and you know all we could do
was see it and hear it now the only
reason i hesitated
at the start there was because it's the
same world war ii guns we're used to
it's like what are you gonna do you
can't
you know you can't fictionalize crazy
futuristic weapons uh you can go the
battlefield route and maybe go with some
experimental weapons that might have
been
left on the table or weren't used so
much but this time you know we we saw a
lot of world war ii staples so you know
it's a good and bad thing you know i i
knew what to expect but as far as how
the gameplay looked and sounded it was
probably strange to say
how it looked like modern warfare from
2019 but not really it's the same game
engine so we're i kind of got that vibe
which was which was cool i think people
are going to be conflicted about this
one so you have all these things from
modern warfare that a lot of us really
love like you have the gun bench you
have the weapon attachment system you
have ammo conversion mods you have red
dot sights in world war ii
and these are things that made that game
so special and that's why they're being
so smartly channeled into this game now
the big question is can you suspend your
disbelief that these things are in world
war ii because obviously these things
are super super modern inventions so it
like that'll make the moment to moment
of it feel a lot more like modern
warfare which is like hugely appealing
to me like i gotta be honest that was
the thing where i was like okay like
maybe i can get behind this if it plays
like modern warfare in world war ii what
were some of the other mechanics richie
that came from modern warfare uh well
it's the same engine like we we keep
discussing but that's that's good in
terms of uh uh some some features we
like some mechanics like sliding peeking
all that's coming back just picture you
know the world war ii setting but uh you
know war zone style of play modern
warfare style of play and you're right
aaron about all these attachments like
i'm not so mixed on that anymore i'm
happy that at the beginning of the
presentation they came out and they said
you know we want to respect history of
course but we are not in this case
creatively beholden to it entirely so
i was ready to suspend my disbelief uh
for some good gameplay and that's okay
they're very open about that they they
want people to have fun i think that's
important but uh it's good to see also
just going back to your question about
the mechanics people are mixed on door
play and peeking and
sliding around cold war had some of it
modern warfare did a really good job
implementing those things i really
enjoyed those tactics and mechanics so
it's good to see them return the other
sort of bonus of that is you don't get
that jarring transition and gameplay
styles you do the the way you get it
between cold war and war zone war zone
was made for modern warfare it's
gameplay style and if you play a lot of
cold war you have to kind of like switch
your brain into a different mode when
you go into warzone the mechanics are
slightly different so the integration is
thought of from the start now they on
that note too they confirm they're gonna
have their own warzone map we haven't
heard more about that yet we don't know
how big it's gonna be we don't know how
big of a change it's gonna be or how
it's gonna be implemented so that's
something we'll we'll have to talk about
a little bit later now the other thing
to talk about here is there were a lot
of rumors going into this that
sledgehammer was extremely rushed in
making this game and there was a concern
about how much content would actually be
there richie do you want to talk about
the launch maps i would be happy to
because it's good news at the
presentation they announced that there
will be 20 maps at launch 16 of them are
6 v6 regular maps and the other 4 are
gunfight 2v2 or 3v3 style maps and
that's huge but one of the biggest
problems at every launch yearly of call
of duty do you know really fault of
their own because you know it's it's not
easy to work on these games a huge
glaring issue that a lot of people like
to bring up is the lack of stuff at
launch especially when it comes to
specifically to multiplayer uh this
doesn't seem to be the case this time
around i don't know the gun lineup but
as far as maps are concerned we are
covered i would say uh very much so it's
a lot of maps to launch a game with i
don't think any call of duty game has
launched with that many maps uh ever so
that's great news that doesn't fully
answer our question as to whether those
maps were rushed but we we do know that
there's gonna be a lot of we know
there's gonna be a lot of them there's
gonna be a lot to do on those maps and
like you know sledgehammer's pretty good
at making their maps i'm kind of an
infinity ward man myself we're getting
20 maps which is a ton we're getting
warzone and we're also getting this
other mode champion hill but we can't
really talk about any of the specific
details of that it is interesting that i
think everybody's been trying to get
away from battle royale recently like
battlefield's not even going to try
their hazard zone mode is something
battle royale-esque but not battle
royale and even call of duty is trying
some mode that isn't quite battle royale
it makes you wonder if we're starting to
get to the tail end of battle royale or
if at least there's enough major
competitors in there that other people
don't really want to try and get into it
further i mean to be fair they already
have warzone so they're one of those
competitors but we'll know more about
that and we'll know more about
multiplayer in upcoming events for now
we just sort of know a little bit about
what we saw with the mechanics of the
game and the
little bit of what we saw with the
single player campaign the way that call
of duty also might appeal to people this
year is it's going to have a campaign
that's actually kind of interesting
because battlefield has completely given
up on their campaign and they're going
to tell their story through mixed media
the same way that warzone did it's funny
like it's battlefield's going towards
the warzone type of storytelling but
call of duty is going to keep their
their yearly campaign and that's going
to appeal to some people like some
people really do want a campaign in
their game so speaking of ritchie what
in this campaign at least in the section
that we saw
seemed like something that you really
wanted to play there were a few details
that i picked up on overall you know
like i mentioned they opened with the
the campaign gameplay and a really
flashy trailer at first so first it was
a trailer that was pretty cool it even
had some i would say battlefield moments
but then they go into a gameplay segment
and it was slow paced and like you know
it didn't get me like super hyped at
first but some things did some parts of
that stood out that would be of course
like the gun play and the music i
haven't seen something like this in
terms of music in a call of duty game
for a while like there are general
soundtracks that are composed and pasted
into any mission when things get hot you
know the music will kick in classic but
the moment-to-moment pacing here at
least in this gameplay example was
really cool you know you're sneaking
around and there's just like one violin
or things get heated and then like the
whole band goes off um i think it worked
really well and again that's something
like the dust that i mentioned that i
don't generally notice uh on my own like
i'll go back and remember call of duty
soundtracks but uh from moment to moment
like that was something new and very
cool there were some who really like
brutal moments to the campaign section
that we saw like people falling out of
the sky on fire or like allies being
executed or
you know people in the basement with um
nazis stomping on the boards overhead
there were quite a few there are quite a
few moments where i kind of like stopped
listening to what the developers were
talking about just because i got it was
pretty intense what i got to say like
there really went for the jugular on not
holding back on warfare and like that is
that's probably accurate to like a world
war ii setting so high level richie you
know at the end of the day do you want a
world war ii game next when it comes to
call of duty overall i'm i'm ready for
it and i'm hopeful that the game will
change my mind there is a lot to like
here i think the biggest difference here
a good example would be i watched the
modern warfare 2019 trailer when it
first dropped and i lost my after
watching this presentation that was
chock full of game play and information
i left the presentation kind of like
okay ready maybe not hyped but what
about you aaron where are you at after
watching this whole presentation what
are your high level thoughts i thought
call of duty was done this year like i
like honestly going into this
presentation i thought they were
finished i thought battlefield
completely had it there are things that
we saw in this campaign that make me
think that now the competition is kind
of back on i still don't know if the
call of duty crowd wants world war ii
but i do know that they loved the gun
play of modern warfare and they loved
the special forces angle of modern
warfare which is being really smartly
channeled here and some of the
battlefield people are gonna miss having
a campaign so maybe call of duty is
gonna have a little bit more of an
appeal to them this is also coming out
very close to battlefield so i think
it's exciting like we're gonna get to
play a battlefield game and then shortly
thereafter we're gonna get to play a
call of duty game where you know we're
not gonna know until we see more from
the multiplayer and the other mode that
they're doing and what the warzone map
is so it's still way too early to tell
but i went from call of duty as done
this year to like okay they they got a
fighting chance they're actually making
smart decisions and this might really
work for some people all right you guys
be sure to like this video and subscribe
to gamespot if you want to see more call
of duty vanguard coverage we're excited
to play and get our hands on it on
november 5th see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you